[Niko:] We are experimenting with some name changes and variations on the channel
So it's all part of that continuing process, trying to optimize and be the best channel we can possibly be
[Music by Johan Lilja]
So, we realize that our channel, just being "samandniko"-- all one word, all lowercase -- is not very good branding
[Carmichael:] Salmon Eagle.
[Niko:] Salmon Eagle is the next alternative, but uh, we held off on that because it's
really cool and we want to wait for the right time to drop it.
Also expect an icon change in the near future.
Hey, you hear this, guys?
The first two videos that get 100,000 views -- in a row --  we get Carmichael(cmike) a new camera.
[Carmichael:] Oh my god.
Canon.
For me?!
[Music by Johan Lilja]
Canon 80D!
[Grunt]
[Music by Johan Lilja]
Oh!
That looks fancy right there.
Ho!
I opened it upside-down.
[Sam:] Dude, these are the nicest camera bags.
[Carmichael:] I know! [Sam:] Just bags?
[Carmichael:] We got lenses!
Full frame 1DX Mark 2.
and then an 11 to 24.
[Sam:] Alright, see, lookit, this is the new lens here.
It's a-- it's a hair. It's a tiny little hair from a tiny little animal.
let's test out this new lens, let's bring it for a ride.
here we go guys, [Strained] new lens.
[Grunts]
alright, how's that look?
[Off camera] - it's good.
[Sam:] Whoa. That's such a big, bulbous lens.
here's the old one.
[Carmichael:] It's a full-- that's a full frame 11 mil. While that's a etsc 11 mil.
[Sam:] That's gonna look crazy at 6K
[Niko:] Can I see your hat for a second?
[Sam:] Would you like to touch it?
[Niko:] I would like to touch your hat for a second. [laugh]
[laughs from everyone]
Corridor...Digital
[Niko laughs]
The "Sam and Niko" channel isn't "Sam and Niko," it's Corridor.
[Sam:] Then why don't we just go back to "C2?"
[Jake:] It's not a second channel
[Sam:] "Corridor Zero."
"Corridor 360."
[Niko:] Do you know why they called the "XBOX 360" the "XBOX 360?"
The real reason is because the XBOX original -- the "XBOX 1" -- came out when the PS2 came out.
So when the next XBOX wanted to come out, they couldn't call it the XBOX 2,
cause the Playstation was at PS3.
It would sound like it was a generation behind.
So they also needed a "3" in their title. But they couldn't call it the XBOX 3
because they didn't have the second one.
So they came up with the next most recognizable number that begins with 3
which is apparently "360."
So that's why it's totally arbitrary-
[Sam:] It's pretty good
[Niko:] Totally arbitrary
Favorite alternate channel name?
[mumbling]
[Off camera] - Yeah.
[Sam:] What if you made that the word?
Rodirroc!
[everyone laughs]
[Niko:] Rodirroc!
[laughs continue]
[Charmichael:] [grunts] What lens is--
[Lens cover clattering on the ground]
This is not a gift, this is a loan from Canon. To experiment with some new lenses
new camerawork for the Sam and Niko channel and the Corridor channel
[Sam:] Exactly. You'll notice that obviously the lens says "MARKETING" on it
Sorry guys, we are actively marketing right now. Apologies for that
All those corporate lens industry product placement videos you see -- this is one of them
Macro 100
Let's do this. You wanna see something really really close up?
Alright, so this has gotta be pretty wonky lookin'
Boom.
Yeah. Gross, right?
[Jake:] It's like a kid in Candy Land.
[Sam:] Look at this.
[Carmichael:] We got the 80D. 60 frames per second at 1080, which is great
And then the 1DX, 4K, 60 frames per second, and 120 frames, 1080
[Niko:] Are you excited, Carmichael?
I'm very excited
And...let's switch cameras.
[Niko:] So here at Corridor, we make our living on YouTube.
It's important for us to study the algorithms that suggests videos
and put your videos in front of new viewers.
Kind of how the whole system works, because the more we understand that and learn that,
the better we can expand our audience
The Sam and Niko channel has gone through a pretty big evolution these last couple of months
[Wren:] How thick it was?
[Niko:] All the colors of the rainbow
[Sam:] Help
[Case being smashed]
[Wall being kicked]
[Sam:] You were shooting a little bit less, but it's all just a little bit better
[Steve:] Oh, I AM the camera!
Oh!
OH!
Oh -- OH SHIT!
[Niko:] A third of our audience watching Sam and Niko wasn't subscribed to the channel a month ago.
We did a big subscription push.
We had a couple segments of me speaking directly to the camera asking people to subscribe
and we did some little end cards that would politely say "Consider Subscribing"
And it worked great
Now we saw something interesting happen
I expected the percentage of unsubscribed viewers to dip
Previously it was 33%, now I expected it to go down to 30, maybe even 25%.
But something interesting happened
Instead, the percentage of unsubscribed viewers on the channel-
[Air compressor running buzzing]
[laugh]
-but then the percentage actually went up
It went up from 33% unsubscribed, to 37% unsubscribed
And that's really strange
With thousands and thousands of new subscribers, we're getting more people
who are unsubscribed to the channel
So why is that, and how does the YouTube algorithm play into that?
I have a bit of a theory
[batman theme]
Now, this is pure speculation, YouTube's algorithm is secret
We don't know how it works, and we can only look at
the numbers on our computer screens to figure it out
So take this with a grain of salt
But, I think, that because the algorithm saw an uptick in engagement and subscribers
it flipped that little switch inside the system
that decided to put our content in front of even more viewers
in front of even more people
It would make sense that the algorithm would notice content bringing in viewers
and therefore put that content in front of even more viewers
And rank it up in search results, in suggested videos and all that kind of stuff
So in other words, by increasing our subscriber base
the algorithm then put our content in front of even more viewers
thereby increasing our percentage of unsubscribed viewers
Sounds backwards, but it worked
So when you guys are browsing Youtube and you're looking at different channels
Take a moment and  look at how they're doing at thumbnails, their titles, their strategies
everybody has all these different ideas as to what works the best
And if you have any ideas yourself, feel free to share them with us because we're all just trying to figure it out.
[laughs]
[Music by Johan Lilja]